welcome to Hannity buckle up get ready
this is the week that we the American
people will really get to see for the
first time just how extreme crazy insane
these Democratic socialists really are
this is just a sneak preview we got a
lot more coming up tonight take a look
we can cancel student loan debt for
ninety five percent of the folks who
thought we will demand that the wealthy
and large corporations start paying
their fair share of taxes we have to do
something to reduce the student debt
which I don't have time to go into now
but we will there's gonna be extremely
ugly you're gonna be shocked by a lot of
what you're here and it's gonna help
Donald Trump and you'll have a front-row
seat to all of it and we're gonna have a
preview real preview coming up we'll
have a rundown of the madness that's all
coming up in a Hannity special mini
monologue but first we do begin tonight
with the Fox News Alert the
representation of intelligence deep
state abuse of power it is now
undeniable as ever tonight we have
brand-new documents we will show you
according to these just released
documents that were obtained by the
American Center for Law and Justice
through the Freedom of Information Act
and a request they put in we now have
what is some of the clearest evidence to
date of what is nothing short of a
attempted coup soft coup against this
president use documents shed even more
light on this timeline of corruption an
effort to try and undermine well first
stop and prevent a president from
winning that they didn't like and rigged
an election but then afterwards to
undermine a duly elected president I
remember a long while back we talked
about this a lot we reported how the
Obama administration in their final days
vastly expanded the Intelligence Sharing
capabilities of America's most powerful
agencies remember we talked about this
executive order twelve triple three and
it was the basis of all this and I was
warning about this as far back as 2017
now we are learning tonight that
literally days before president Trump's
inauguration well we find out the Office
of the Director of National Intelligence
under James clapper
was eagerly pushing to totally overhaul
the sharing of raw intelligence
which expanded the sharing of this
intelligence raw intelligence from just
three agencies to seventeen Wow why
would they as an outgoing administration
one all of a sudden impose standards on
the incoming administration standards
they never imposed on themselves for
eight years that's the big question
according to new documents well the
Director of National Intelligence office
was eager to get the new procedures
quote signed by the Attorney General
before the conclusion of this
administration and not only that around
the same time the DNI General Counsel's
name is Robert litt wrote quote really
want to get this done and so does the
boss and a likely reference to clapper I
don't know maybe he's any chance at all
that the boss is Obama I keep asking the
question what did Obama Biden know when
did they know it all hopefully we'll get
answers one day remember all this
Russian interference happened on the
Biden Obama watch even though people
like Devin unas former chairman House
Intel committee he was warning the Biden
Obama administration that Russia was
going to do all of this he was warning
them in early 2014 they didn't listen
they let it happen they did nothing
happened on their watch not Trump's
watch and here's the kicker the NSA
discussed in early January 2017 that it
could quote have a signature from the AG
as early as this week certainly prior to
the 20th of January that would be the
date of president Trump's inauguration
okay let's break this down what does it
all mean
for eight years the Obama administration
well they did not allow the sharing of
raw intelligence with 17 separate
agencies they only allowed three and
then literally in the final days just
before Donald Trump is about to become
president
there is a complete overhaul of our
intelligence gathering apparatus to give
a lot more access of the most sensitive
raw and in many cases not even confirm
material to deep state bureaucrats
without getting any input from the new
incoming administration it was
championed by clappers DNI it was signed
by Loretta Lynch as you see there
remember these are some of the same
people involved in the phony Russia
collusion probe and in the case of the
Attorney General what really happened on
that tarmac in Phoenix Arizona when she
says she was talking to Bill Clinton for
45 minutes about grandkids just days
before she's supposed to make a decision
whether to indict his wife or not
crossfire hurricane Hilary's exoneration
without investigation don't forget
vastly expanding access to this
intelligence material meant it was
harder to trace the information harder
to weed out the leakers harder to hold
anyone in the deep state accountable
they knew exactly what they were doing
they were trying to put the intelligence
on the radar of as many people as
possible so they wouldn't be able to
find the people that knew what they did
was an abuse of power
it was corruption at the worst level but
it's still being exposed anyway look at
how urgent these messages are they knew
they had two weeks to get this done
really is this what they cared about
with two weeks to go deep state and a
mad scramble looks like clapper was
leading the way let's take a look now
you combine this what we already know
about Oh Hillary Clinton literally
funneling money through a law firm
Perkins Cooley then hiring an op
research firm then hiring a guy by the
name of Christopher steel Christopher
steel puts together a bunch of documents
becomes a dossier the dirty Russian
dossier that was used to rig the 2016
election like they rigged the primary
installed from Bernie Sanders he had no
shot from the beginning the same people
involved in unmasking the secret
informants it's all coming into focus
it's now getting clearer every day
they're not getting away with this we
told you the curtain was being lifted it
is we told you you heard the Attorney
General and Lindsey Graham act one the
molar report whether they want to side
drop my pen whether they want to believe
it is gone act two now the deep state
the conspiracy theory Democrats and the
media mob they know that the day of
reckoning is absolutely near look at you
know the Cowardly Schiff who's panicking
because he's quote running out of time
to interview Muller and continue with
his endless conspiracy theories his hoax
his life the great irony is every time I
look at
this idiot who won't come on our show
we've offered him four straight hours
three hours radio one-hour TV is that
he's the only one that we have on tape
conspiring with a Russian or someone he
thinks is a Russian about getting dirt
to influence our elections yeah that
would be the Cowardly shift take a look
we have been in private discussions with
a special counsels office it's not clear
that he will refuse to come in
voluntarily we are negotiating what the
conditions of that appearance might be
but yes we are running out of time it's
my hope that we'll reach a final
conclusion either he's going to come in
voluntarily we're going to or we're
gonna have to subpoena him I hope that
we'll reach that decision this week
because we want to have him come in
during July and I think that's going to
be the case Jake whether it's
voluntarily or involuntary by subpoena
we actually have a dossier on the
Cowardly Schiff just his own words his
own lies his own conspiracy theories
that he digs a deeper hole every day
with mark my words we are inching closer
and closer to holding those who abuse
power and those that lied like him and
the media mob accountable